ah yeah I just want to ask you what you
remember about working with Pacino or
you remember meeting him when you
trained his dog and and don't you have
something that you're going to send me
and maybe we could post it I am going to
send you a canceled check receipt from
Al Pacino
um this is what I remember the first
time I met Al Pacino I had to meet a
driver in Manhattan had to get into his
car to drive me to The Brownstone that
Pacino was living in so I go upstairs
and I walk in the room there's Al Pacino
David Mamet do I have that right and
Elliott Gould
and they're playing Atari baseball
and I'm here to train the dog they're in
the other room playing baseball I said
hello now guy and you got to learn how
to do this I'm not coming over every day
to train your dog and so they said why
don't you join us and play some baseball
with us we need a fourth that was the
first time I met him after that and he
got stoned with him I didn't get someone
at that point after that after that he
had another house in Westchester County
I went there working with his dogs lucky
and Susie and that's the point where he
was getting ready to do Scarface
so when I was in the house I was
training the dog he was in another room
right here you cockroach all
these different things he was practicing
but then the funny part about it was he
kind of he grew up in an Italian
neighborhood Italians and Jews very
similar and all they kept saying yeah
one you want a sandwich hungry you want
a sandwich
nice guy really nice guy wow really nice
guy everyone and every one of the
celebrities I worked with I'm trying to
think I had to be one
one guy that you're just like man he
wasn't very nice I'm sure you there was
a couple you won't say that they kind of
became an one was a news anchor
that kind of became sort of an
they were cool and once they got a
little popularity they became kind of
like ah yeah I could I could give you a
long by the way one quick mention
The Mickey Mouse Club don't forget that
I was the creature keeper on the new
Mickey Mouse Club for years wow for
years and so now I can't look at those
girls anymore because I knew them when
they were little so I can't look at them
anymore who are they who are they now
imagine their names but they're very
famous very very famous and so I would
go to Orlando and do the Mickey Mouse
Club as the creature keeper I got some
videos of that someday when you come
over the house actually it's pretty it's
pretty funny and I had to do why because
we like you the whole Mickey Mouse thing
it's pretty funny jeez